[Applause]
hey David nice to meet you nice to meet
you too I hear we both lead data science
teams I specialize in getting data going
at early stage startups what do you do
basically the same thing but more in a
larger organization I developed data
science teams but taking it to the next
level trying to get them to be able to
sustain their teams and be able to do
their data analytic architecture
well you know that sounds great actually
getting data started from scratch there
are so many things that are frustrating
often we kind of just run into a lot of
barriers it must be nice to be somewhere
where everything is established and
running smoothly you know it would be
nice we have our challenges too large
organizations tend to be very slow
especially government organizations and
we tend to be more reactive than
proactive but we're leading to being
able to change that to be more proactive
in our organizations you know maybe I
can share with you some of the things
I've learned about getting data science
off the ground and then I would love to
hear what you've learned about doing
data science great that'd be great
thanks so I thought a lot about what's
kind of the root problem of some of
these things that we Face getting data
science started or or you know even the
later stages and what I've concluded is
this it's really
that hope for d data science is so high
in terms of what we can deliver but the
understanding of how to set teams up for
success is so low and this can mean that
your organization kind of accidentally
makes it impossible for you to do the
job they were so excited to bring you in
to do in the first place so if you run
into these problems who can you turn to
to help you kind of solve these
organizational issues that you're
facing and I think the answer is it's
you it's you the data scientist it's us
the data scientists maybe this shouldn't
be our job uh but in my experience the
best chance of success is if we take the
lead in helping our organizations learn
how to make us
successful so if we're going to do this
I think it's helpful to understand why
we find ourselves in this situation
where there's this big gap between the
hope for what we can deliver and the
understanding of how to help us do
that so first of all the Hope part if
you put yourself in the mind of a CEO or
another executive who decided to bring a
data science team into an organization
these are the kinds of messages they're
getting data is the world's most
valuable
resource right so if you are someone
who's in charge of the longterm
strategic direction of an organization
you want to make sure you're not missing
these big opportunities to be doing
things with data and then I think on the
flip side of that is fear most CEOs
think their organizations have to evolve
or die whether they're small and early
stage or big and established the world
is changing quickly they need to stay on
The Cutting Edge and be doing things
that are
transformative and part of that is being
smart about how they use data so I think
it's these big highlevel ideas that get
people excited about what we can do
deliver and years ago now I was hired
into a Transit software company under
these circumstances the CEO was the one
who decided that they needed to hire a
data scientist and he told me I know we
have a lot of data and I know there's
more valuable things we could be doing
with it and I'm not sure exactly what
that is but we need you to help figure
it out so I went in knowing there was
this uncertainty where I would have to
help find the value in the data and and
help the company realize it but I also
knew I had the backing of the CEO and so
this seemed like a pretty good
situation so I arrived and started
talking to the lead engineer about
getting access to the data and he said
oh no I can't give you access to the
data like we've built our data pipelines
with these particular needs for our
production system and it's not built for
analytic queries it's not safe for me to
let you get the
data so so so immediately this is a
problem right and so I had to keep
pestering him I can't do anything if you
can't get me the data So eventually he
agreed okay we can try running a query
so you can get some data so I wrote the
query I checked with him he approved it
and I sent it off and I
waited and waited and it seemed like it
was taking a really long time so
eventually I wandered down the hall to
ask him if he knew what was going on and
he was not available to talk to me
because he was in the middle of an
emergency
situation all the buses in our product
on the maps had stopped moving and why
had that happened of course it was
because of my one
query so that was the end for a long
time of me getting access to that
data and this kind of like very basic
problem is not unusual I talk to other
data scientists and data leaders these
are the kinds of things we Face a lot um
so
so there's three buckets of things I
think that we need that organizations
don't really understand coming in one is
analysis ready data and this can go
wrong in several ways one is you can't
get access to the data or it's not in a
form that's safe for analytics another
might be that the data you need for the
project you're doing doesn't exist it's
not really even being collected or maybe
it is being collected and you can get
access to it but the data management
practices are so non-existent that it's
messy to the point where it's almost
unusable another thing we need is cross
team support so in the situation I was
in at the transit company the
engineering team could have solved my
problem they had the ability to get the
data into an analytics data warehouse
right but they weren't expecting to need
to do this work no one realized the data
scientists would need any support and
they had a list of high priority items
that they were already struggling to be
able to address with the capacity they
had so they weren't going to prioritize
this and this can also happen in the
other direction sometimes people are
thrilled to see you arrive as the data
person because they think my team has
data problems we spend way too much time
reporting here's someone who can solve
this for us and then you can get a lot
of incoming requests which can be
helpful in understanding what your
organization needs but if you can't
control that you end up spending all
your time reacting to these requests and
never get to those potentially really
high impact projects which are what
people really wanted data scientists for
in the first
place and the third thing is space for
uncertainty so unlike almost everything
else that organizations
do data science projects depend on the
contents of the data in a way that makes
it hard to know whether they're worth
doing until we've kind of already done
them and so this can make it really hard
to fit into the normal way that your
organization plans
work so if you find yourself dealing
with these kinds of problems what do you
do and I think in my experience there's
a set of tactics that work here that I
think of as Guerilla data science
tactics so this means maybe not doing
things ideally the way that we should be
doing them but doing what we have have
to to make it work in the situation
we're in so being Scrappy and clever and
working around the obstacles in our way
but gorilla of course comes from gorilla
Warfare and warfare is not the right
mindset for us to be in right so as
frustrated as we might get with some of
our colleagues they aren't trying to
make things difficult for us we're all
want to making we're all wanting to make
it work we just haven't figured out how
to do that yet so instead maybe we think
about this as gorilla data
science powerful but
friendly so what does this actually mean
in
practice there's a series of steps that
I have found success with in getting
data science off the ground the first
step is scan for opportunity so this
means being heads up in your
organization and looking for the overlap
of what's valuable to the organization
and what you're able to do with
data and once you found that
opportunity the next step is show don't
tell so it can be tempting to explain to
people what you're thinking and what
you're planning to do and what you need
from them and how this is going to play
out to get Buy in but in my experience
at least early on this is usually a
waste of time what you need to do is
build the thing at least a skinny
version of the thing so that they can
see the vision you have in a more
concrete way and have something to react
to next take the data and run so this
doesn't mean stealing the data or
hacking into the data but it means that
if you can't get access in the way that
you ultimately will need to you have to
do whatever it takes to get an initial
data set maybe this means befriending an
engineer who does have access and asking
them to just help you get a one-time
data set that you can get started
with and then once you've used that data
set to build something that delivers on
that
opportunity nail the landing and what
this means is communicate so all of
these things you've done up to this
point don't matter if no one knows what
you did or doesn't understand why it's
valuable and I think it's almost
impossible to
overinvestment way until it connects
with people and they really get it and
also communicating broadly so not just
your primary stakeholder or your team
but everyone around the organization
make friends and talk to them all the
time about what you're
doing and then once you've done this
it's time to up the ante so once you've
done an initial project that shows value
and people know about it and understand
it you want to use that organizational
Goodwill to do do something that's maybe
higher risk but higher impact than next
time and so you go through this cycle
again so when I found myself in this
position of not being able to access the
data that I was there to find Value in I
was at the scan for opportunity
stage and the opportunity that presented
itself we had just raised money we had a
growing employee base people needed to
understand what was going on with the
company and so we we worked on business
metrics not what I had come to do but it
was the opportunity we had at the time
and so we started building a flex stash
board and deployed it and were sharing
it with people so they could see what we
were
doing the data here did not come from
that production system but we were able
to find Scrappy ways to pull information
in from around the company to feed this
dashboard and then we communicated it to
everyone we showed it in company
meetings we talked to teams about how
they could use it and that got us some
Goodwill to do the next step so now
we're back to scan for
opportunity and this time the company
was getting into a new product in the
area of microtransit which is like an
Uber pool for Transit agencies and
universities and this runs on an
algorithm so from our data science
Viewpoint we thought well of course we
understand how the algorithm works but
that's not the same as understanding how
it'll play out in the real world and we
thought we could figure that out figure
out where it works well and where it
doesn't in which situations by using
simulation and so now we had this
Goodwill so I thought this time we can
do it right I went to the product
manager and talked about our idea and
why we thought it would be valuable and
what we needed from the engineering
teams to do this and she said oh that's
interesting we're not going to
prioritize this no one's asking me for
it we have a long list of high
priorities items and I already can't do
them all with the team that I have so
we're just not going to be able to help
you with this so back to show don't tell
how could we build a version of this
that we could show people on our
own so in this case because we were
using simulation we were creating our
own data so that's problem solved but we
still needed access to the algorithm so
we went to engineering with this onetime
ask just help us get access so that we
can run this algorithm offline it won't
interfere with your production system
and will leave you alone and so we got
that so then we built a shiny app to
create inputs we scheduled all our
simulations we created reports for
different scenarios so then we had
something really cool to show people so
we went back to our team and the product
manager and showed them this and within
our department people thought you know
this is interesting but it's kind of
like a toy it's not really you know part
of our software it's just kind of an
interesting side project but we kept
talking about it and one day I showed it
to the chief Revenue officer and he
immediately saw the value in this
because he's thinking about the customer
right the customer is uncomfortable with
this algorithm they need to be able to
see how this is going to work for them
before they're willing to put this out
in the world and we very quickly became
part of our marketing and sales process
and also part of how we communicated to
our investors why this was important and
what it actually was so now we had got
gotten to that point of this high impact
this was the kind of thing that the CEO
had wanted to bring the data science
team in for to begin
with so a few Reflections about what's
important in this process one is to
maximize speed and autonomy so even
though we're in this privileged position
where people have great faith that we
can do amazing things even though they
don't quite know what they are we still
have to start delivering eventually
right so we have a limited amount of
time and in my experience the best way
to maximize speed is to maximize
autonomy of the team and this doesn't
mean working in a silo or not
collaborating with other teams but what
it means to me is that that iterative
data science development process you
need to be able to do that without
running into places where you need help
from another team because that's what's
going to slow you
down the other thing is to build
foundations wherever possible along the
way so even though we're doing these
Scrappy things in our Guerilla data
science tactics everywhere we have a
chance we want to start building things
that we can build again on later so
building data pipelines that we can
schedule um building our packages that
we can reuse all of those
things and these are the things where my
teams have found posit connect to be
really helpful so instead of every time
we need to deploy a dashboard or we need
to deploy an app or we need to run a
Cron job having to go ask engineering
for help with getting that set up it was
just a onetime ask help us set up posit
connect and then we're often running on
our own we can do all these things
without constantly needing
support so if you've gone through this
process and you've gotten to that first
really high impact result pat yourself
on the back you can declare Victory and
now you've completed step one
because this is just the beginning to
create momentum but going forward you
can't do things this way and have a
sustainable and scalable data science
practice particularly the take the data
and run step needs to evolve and David I
would love to hear what you've learned
about doing data science at scale and
how you've done some of these things
happy to
share so youan when you're hearing you
talk it really brought back a lot of
memories
I almost felt like I was in a episode of
this is my life because I went through
so many of these things similar to what
you just
did and I just couldn't understand why
it was so hard to get the data I mean it
took me two years two years to actually
have the head of IT of human capital of
it tell her staff if David and his team
need the data they get the data there
was a lot of colling a lot of begging a
lot of pulling hair out a lot of pulling
hair
out but I think what really came down to
was showing her that we can get answers
in minutes instead of days or weeks at
times let me give you a small example of
our data access at that time when I
first joined this
organization we had this Personnel data
warehouse where 18,000 roughly 18,000
civil certain data employees are there
in that information all the data
information about
them now I have to go to this web
interface of this very well-known
backend database that we have to access
and there are some queries on there that
I can pull that maybe have what 10 15 20
different attributes of of an employee
it takes me maybe a minute to two
minutes to have that thing load once I
access that query then I have to add
other attributes for that employee
depending on what I'm
doing that's another 10 to 30 seconds
for each attribute and if I got the
wrong one because I don't have a data
dictionary
I've got to pull that back that's
another 10 to 30 seconds add another one
another 10 to 30 seconds imagine doing
that for 450 different
attributes and I could only pull down
750,000
cells at one
time not rows or observations cells and
if I needed to do historical data 10
years back across all my centers it
could be days before I get all the data
aligned and please don't make a mistake
because then I got to do it all over
again so it was just amazing why can't I
get to all this data there had to be a
better way and there is I think I hope
so it takes a lot of information it
takes somebody's that's going to take
what you start it and take it to the
next level by advocating everything
you've done and being able to talk to
leaders and tell them this is why we
need to do it when we got to the end of
our journey which is very similar to
yours I thought I had built a mansion I
had all of these different applications
out there that we can showcase things
but didn't really did I
really what I had was a facade with a
bunch of little bitty trailers in the
back and they were nice trailers don't
get me wrong they were good they worked
they worked well they work well together
but they individual little things all
the time there was no interface or or
any way for me to really share this
across the Enterprise there wasn't any
way for me to really get it out there
and show showcase to the people
so we have to do something different so
what's next well I started thinking
about this and it really all starts with
the data as elain has mention the data
is the key on everything we do it is the
oil the next oil is it our most vital
commodity that we have so you have to
think about how you develop your data
Foundation what you have to do to get
that data from having to go grab it from
somebody and put it into an to be able
to get a pipeline that automatically
gets it to you but to do that you have
to set expectations with your leaders
because they'll come to you you know 10
15 years ago they was can you just do it
like
Google Now it's can you just make it
like chat
GPT it takes a while to do that I can't
do that immediately because I don't want
I don't have access to the data and two
I don't want to see a lot of
hallucinations especially when we're
trying to get back to the moon and on
the Mars we want to make sure we have
this
right so I needed to create an
understanding level set the perspect
perceptions of everybody in the
organization but another key that I
found was we need to differentiate
between it and data
science it is the
pipeline to get us the data the data
science that's where we do the magic as
they so-called tell me to be able to
change things over and give them some
kind of answers so how do you do
that well several years ago I developed
this uh probably a little over a decade
ago I developed this framework that I
call Knowledge
architecture and let me give you a quick
little story as to how this all derived
and came up so you can understand what
I'm trying to get to here again over a
decade ago I was leading the small team
in a Knowledge Management Group down in
Johnson Space Center and I was meeting
with my taxonomist and my web developer
and we were talking over things and the
taxonomist went to looked at the web
developer and she says I need access to
the
metadata and he the web developer
adamantly said no they went back and
forths on this for 10 15
minutes I finally said time out guys
let's just go to respective Corners
let's let's talk about this later I want
to go meet with my taxonomist separately
come to find out this conversation been
going on for couple of months now and
with no resolution I said first off tell
me what's the definition of metadata in
her mind the data on the data okay give
me some
examples
author abstract date created title all
information about the document that she
was trying to categorize and classify in
her system went to the web developer I
had the same
conversation he gave me this basically
the same definition all right give me
some examples field type length size
anything you want to talk about a
database what's that information again
level setting the organization to have
them communicate same definition
different examples once I got them
talking on the same way they were able
to get that information to them so it
was really more about understanding each
other's world to be able to do that so
that's when I started thinking we need a
liaison we need a group and that's where
knowledge architecture came into play of
somebody that can talk all three
languages to get this information across
so what is knowledge architecture This
Is My Mind knowledge architecture is a
combination of Knowledge Management
informatics in data
science Knowledge Management is the
strategy for how we ident identify store
analyze and visualize our information
our data informatics again is that
pipeline they're the ones that get that
data get our commodity our oil from one
place through the processing in order
for us to get it out there we can
utilize it and then data science is the
algorithms and methodologies we use to
turn that data into some kind of
actionable
knowledge and by doing
that and combining all of that we start
to develop our data Foundation
I've set some expectations I'm
communicating across I creating that
understanding and I'm differentiating
what's between it and data that gets me
started to develop this framework that
we can start creating those data anal
analytical pipelines that allow us to
more efficiently use our data in our
organization so I started this again it
all starts with the
data think back when you if you've seen
Raiders of the Lost Arc in the last
scene where they're taking that Arc and
put it in into a warehouse and it's
going back and you don't see it again
for forever that's kind of how we've
done our data NASA's been around for 60
plus years we stored a lot of data and
it just kind of sitting there somewhere
and it first started in filing cabinets
then it went to file servers then to
SharePoint databases all in the same
structure we've always collected the
data just to store
it and and that's basically it we need
to do better I think you talked about it
Analytics and Analysis ready data we
need data we need to connect data with
analysis in mind we need curated AIML
ready data sets and that's what that's
will support us no more of this takes me
80% of my time to Cle clean the data in
order for me do my analysis I want to
get to the data and start working and
doing the analysis so some of the things
we need to do when we look at that is we
think about our orchestration and
ingestion and this comes by working with
it and differentiating that so it will
take somebody as to lead this effort
some somebody like a chief analytics
officer somebody that's that's going to
work with the senior leaders in order to
show this is the difference of why we
need to do this too many times we put
analytics into it yes data science is
code but we're not it developers we do
our own thing we have ways of doing
things that we need to differentiate
between the it and data science life
cycle so we need to make make sure we
get that done so how we're going to
ingest from our data sources into
various different things so we want to
take our dat our my Personnel data
warehouse what I'm kind of doing right
now is taking my data from my Personnel
data warehouse based on the types of
analysis that we need to do and creating
these AI ml Cur rated data sets so we're
taking it through those systems we're
transforming it and I'll talk a little
bit about that in a minute but we're
getting to the point to where it's ready
for us to be able to use it but you also
have to make sure that somebody's
talking to it
security again if you're in a large
organization like NASA we've been around
many year we've been around before there
was a network I went through the Cisco
versus novel phase of who's going to
who's going to end up being the the
networking
organizations uh but each Center did
their own way we got these firewalls
that all over the place that if you
don't talk to I security early you're
going to be stopped in your tracks very
quickly so you got to make sure you get
them involved they can be a headache
sometimes but it's well worth it to get
in there and talk to them to make sure
that they understand why you need access
to data and how to get to that
data but here's the key in my mind you
need to work with the data owners and
the data stewards to get them to
understand their role in the
organization too many times the data
owner and these are the people that run
the business side the person that
actually owns the data for that business
process or the person in that's a data
Steward that understands the processes
for how that data goes through they need
to understand their responsibility too
many times they've given up those
responsibilities to it no it doesn't own
the data they get it to you the data
owner shown them so you got to make sure
they understand what they need to do get
them involved show them the value as the
lame said of if we use your data
correctly this is what we can do for you
guys and then that leads us it's again
it's it's we as data scientists may not
it may not necess be our role but we
have to take it on because nobody else
is doing it right now
we have to advocate for data illiteracy
and data governance we have to get
people to understand everybody in the
organization should be somewhat data
literate so they can help us help them
and by data literacy the ability to to
read work with analyze or communicate
with data and whatever their role is
whether that's a project manager a you
administrator or anything they all need
to know how to work with their data and
that helps us help them so we've got to
advocate for these types of things
within an organization to really raise
the level of what we're trying to do and
make it
sustainable so to how do we create the
sustainable pipeline how do we get to
where we get our all data sources it
goes through some data sources into our
uh our data lake or our data mesh or our
data water fountain or whatever we want
to call it uh it's all there en able to
be shared and visualize it so before I
get there I going to give you another
quick
story I talked earlier about how I got
the data and how it took me so long to
get that
data well I didn't tell you the next
part of this pipeline once I got that
query built little button up there that
says download CSV file okay I download
the CSV file maybe one file maybe 10 20
30 files I have to download then I put
that on my
laptop and on my laptop I open up our
studio vs code Tableau whatever we're
using to injust the data start working
start doing our visualization our
analysis and do that and I create these
great applications we create these great
dashboards then it comes time to present
it so here I go take my laptop go to one
meeting plug it in show this is what
we're doing like that guy go to the next
meeting show it again go to the next
meeting show it again oh you want to
change hold on there you go that was our
pipeline that's what we had to do you
know no no we can do better than this we
have to do better than this so how do we
do this well we do have to think about
ingestion and that ingestion requires us
to be able to turn our data as we're
taking that out of our raw data set or
my Personnel data warehouse I've got to
use my scripts use my containers use
whatever I need to do however my
pipeline set up to take that from a raw
data
set and then turn it into a trusted data
set so it comes into my data Lake that's
my trust the data set for my data
scientist then we start curating it
let's say it's a demog said uh something
on demographics of my employees so I
created this demographic data set then I
start curating it I break break out the
columns I need to break out get it all
ready so that it's ready for analysis
and that data set gets updated on a
regular basis and that data set is what
my data scientist use for any and
all demographic analysis we've created
data dictionary data glossery so
everybody knows how the calculations
goes and how they utilizes we created
wikis to share that information so all
of that's there so that everybody's
using the same data set because in the
previous way with that downloaded from
the web I may pull some data somebody
else will pull some data somebody else
pull some data we probably don't have
the same results because we're all
pulling it on different days or maybe we
had different fields this way we're
saying this is the data that you're
using for demographics and that go into
our into our as a curated data set and
then that curated data set can then be
used to share it across the organization
for analysis visualizations internally
and externally across our organization
that all fits into our pipeline so you
got raw trusted curated shared but you
have to have an understanding of your
storage how are you going to store it
what are you going to do with it what
type of systems are you going to use for
storage and then from that you have the
integration piece how do you access that
storage API Direct access odbc what what
are you going to use to access that type
of information then how are you going to
analyze it and then eventually present
it so the way I usually talk to about
with my organizations or my managers you
want me to present you some information
you want me to visualize this for you I
have to be able to analyze it in order
for me to analyze it I have to be able
to integrate with that I have to be able
to connect to it I have to be able to
access it with the right permissions in
order for me to be able to do that I
have to know where it's stored and how
it's stored I've got probably 30 40
different databases out there I have to
keep an eye on and track on and see
where where we're getting the various
data from so there's a lot of things you
have to do but that's why when they say
can't you just do it like chat GPT or do
it this is what it takes for me to do
that in order for me to do that you've
got to give me the funding you've got to
give me the authority you've got to give
me the access to do that once they see
that they start to say great you can do
that let's go forward and then starting
to get this information quicker and
faster and we can do it on the Fly then
they're starting to see the value of
what we're really trying to do and
they're starting to say we want more of
that and once they get hooked on that
they really want to see that information
because I keep trying to tell them and
and probably one I did I didn't
emphasize enough and and you do need an
advocate I'm constantly going to
meetings and talking about this somebody
has to be there to keep telling them why
they need this because if you don't
they'll forget because management
changes people new people come in you've
got to go back and tell the story all
over again you've got to be able to do
that and be able and consistently do
that and share those stories with you so
once you have all of that you may end up
something like this now the one on the
left the the little diagram there is
just something I created that I go and
this is actually U animated and
integrated and I can in like Dynamic
links and things that I can show to my
managers to show all the different
pieces that we have but my analytical
architecture first starts with the
people understand what type of users you
have both the end users your data
scientist your business intelligence
analysts all the different people that
going to be using the data then you work
through how do you create that data
pipeline what are you going to use for
that are are you going through what
types of different codes mechanisms
repositories to to share the documents
and and the code configuration how are
you going to store it in some kind of
container on a repos again how you going
to integrate with that data on number
four again what type of apis and this is
another thing I just thought of apis
talking to my it guy who's creating all
these API for
me finally figured out we have a
difference in what what we need apis for
again same definition different use
they're using apis to pull data and put
it on a website on a web browser they
need one maybe two data sets or or two
fields or observations coming through
there I need apis that's going to pull
massive amount of data over to my
storage again doing the same thing but
just causes different resour s ources
and and I have slowed and broken a lot
of servers over my years doing these
type of things so I have to really talk
to my it about how do we set these apis
up and what we're trying to do so those
are things you have to consider when
you're doing these things then you have
to look at your data sources and
understand what are different types of
connections we have a lot of different
databases but we don't have all of the
modules that those databases may need we
don't have all of the connectivity to
some of those databases sometimes they
give us access we can we can do read
access some times we don't so there's a
lot of things you have to work through
and try to and try to get there I mean
it's it's difficult but it's well worth
somebody getting in there and trying to
work with them to take this done then
you can start thinking about how are you
going to store that into a data Lake and
get your curated data such and then the
fun then the fund really starts for a
data scientist how do we start turning
that into some kind of uh visualization
application or something it could be
some kind of no code or low code tool
like alterick n or something like that
or something where we're using more High
code and and ml devops with with our
posit servers we got vver that helps us
with some of our modeling we've got
different things or ml flow or cube flow
there's a lot of different things but
that gives us opportunity to do so many
things and my team is both Python and R
and we can do a lot of that within
within those ecosystems right now then
you've got your business intelligence
how you going to presentent it out there
Tableau powerbi again you can do that in
shiny um or then building some kind of
analytical application but the one key
is always always always always have a
group doing some kind of research on the
next technologies that are coming out
there because if you're not keeping up
to date or at least understanding what's
going on you're going to be two years
behind by the time you decide it's time
for me to move so you need to make sure
you research as well as you can to make
sure that thing F you you you got some
kind of momentum going so when the
managers ask you your executive leaders
ask you what's the next thing you need
to do you're ready to go because you've
done your
research so that should hopefully take
you from Daya confusion where you get
your Lego spread all over the place to
data intelligence where you use your
algorithms your methodologies to create
some kind of actionable knowledge
something that's useful for your
organization through that process so
it's kind of a little little
visualization there to that some
managers really like to see it they get
it they like those pictures you know for
some and this helps them understand why
it's important for us to get from one
level to the
other so I think Elena said it earlier
hopefully we've stuck The
Landing and and that's my story that was
that was so helpful to hear thank
you you know I'm still stuck on that
part at the beginning about two years to
get access to the data but that's a
really good reminder for me that
patience and persistence can pay off in
the end that that is true and really for
me it was really validation that knowing
that others are have suffered along with
me or suffering along with me with the
journey they taking But realize that it
is worth it in the end to to continue on
the perseverance that you're doing so
thank you very much everybody thank
you thank you so much David and elain
for joining us here today and I'm so
happy that you both got to meet here in
person and that so many of us get to
meet this week um feel free to take a
seat for the
Q&A
I'm Rachel Dempsey I lead our customer
marketing here at posit and host our
weekly data science hangout where you
may have met Elaine or David
there we'd like to open up this
opportunity to ask some questions to
elain and David and so you'll see on the
screen here you can use that short link
to go over to
slido I know we're not going to have
time for every single great question
right now so David and and Ela are also
going to join me in the lounge right
next door uh right after this
too um and so I'll get things kicked off
and thank you Hadley for helping gather
questions for me um but alen you
mentioned it's almost impossible to
overinvestment data scientists because
spending a lot of time figuring this out
doesn't feel like the work we're
supposed to be doing but what I found
really helpful is trying to get inside
the head of the audience whoever that is
so if you're presenting to the CEO
that's that's one perspective if you're
presenting to it that's a completely
different perspective um but I think
usually when we start thinking about how
to present work we've done ourselves
we're really in the process like we
we tend to present it the way that we
did it right and so I often try and get
myself to think to go through three
rounds of like okay this is what makes
sense to me but now let me think again
about my audience and what they want to
get from this and what is the one thing
that I want to make sure they take away
and then I change the way I present it
and then I do that again because it's
really hard to get out of get out of
that kind of data science mindset into
the you know if I'm the CEO I have to
make a decision about this next week I
ask myself like if if I were her what
would I do after seeing this and am I
getting that point across absolutely
thank you David I I loved when you were
kind of walking across the stage saying
you're bringing your laptop from one
meeting to the next across NASA and I
was wondering how are you doing this
today yeah I mean we've come a long way
since since that time frame so we've
been able to implement a lot of
different uh capabilities um
it co kind of helped a little bit
unfortunately I hate to say that that it
helped but it really put some emphasis
on the need for being able to share data
more easily across the organization so
there was some funding that came up so
we've had things for business
intelligence NASA actually had six
Tableau servers across the agency at
that time so we Consolidated them down
to one and be able to share some
business intelligence but then we also
have our posit server that allows us now
to to use our connect server to do some
of the other things whether it's a shiny
application or created books or wikis or
presentations all of those things that
go up to that make it easier so now we
have one location where we created these
in Portals we call them where they can
go to that one landing page and connect
to all these various different types of
capabilities thank you um I see a lot of
the questions starting to come in now
and one was how can one person teams
advocate for it and data science
differentiation I don't know if Elaine
you want to take that
one yeah I think um when you're when
you're a oneperson team sometimes you
have to do some of everything and so I
think it's about um figuring out where
to meet in the middle and helping people
understand like David was talking about
speaking the same language um so teams
I've been on especially when we're
getting started we sometimes use tools
kind of in that Gap we've used DBT as a
way that we can think about structuring
the data and it's a little more friendly
for um you people more on the
engineering side to understand how
that's coming in and then we build out
from there so I think you know you you
kind of have to do whatever it takes
when you're just one person but start to
show people this is what this might look
like and these are the different steps
in the process even if you're doing more
than one of them to begin with thank you
did you have anything you wanted to add
there no no this is great interest I
mean I mean 20 years ago is probably me
and a bottle of whiskey with the IT guy
you know you say let's talk so
okay um another question um and I'll ask
this to you first David is what if you
have colleagues that are trying to make
it difficult to get data for the sake of
their job security that's unfortunately
that's common you I get a lot of that U
um I I had this
one teammate that needed some data from
an organization and she requested to go
talk to the individuals and and when she
got to the meeting there were 17 other
folks in that meeting questioning why do
you need access to that data uh and it
it a lot of it came down they were
afraid they were going to lose their job
so you really got to show them you had
to find a way of showing them that it's
it's not about taking away
responsibility of taking away job duties
making it easier for them how do we make
this easier together how do we how do we
share how do I include you in that
process in that pipeline you know but be
honest sometimes that job may become
irrelevant so what do I do to get you to
change into a different role set a
different different things so that's
where you really need to work with
managers okay these things may change
how do we get this person to still have
a viable meaningful job but it may not
be what they're doing right now because
our pipelines have changed to kind of
supersede all of that
now thank you okay one other question
was I'll ask this to you Elaine what
advice do you have for those of us
trying to hand off processes we create
to our stakeholders rather than
maintaining them in
perpetuity that's an interesting
question um so I think it it depends a
little on the situation of of what
you're trying to handoff and why and
sometimes I think there can be
intermediate steps where you can um do
the handoff in different ways and maybe
work your way back uh one example
someone was asking about yesterday was
using pins to share data U and I was
explaining a way that we've done this
where we in the process of running our
markdown files and Cordo documents we
pin some things in Connect that are just
csvs that people can then take and do
some of their own processes with so even
though at that point the reports we're
generating are still doing a lot of
analysis we're giving people a way into
the middle of that process where they
can start to participate and build on
what we're doing and then work back to
kind of where we started
definely okay I think we have time for
two more questions here but uh one of
the questions was we all love free stuff
but aside from hiring well what have
been the best investments you've made
that cost serious
money best investment well
I the simple answer for me to start off
with if we're not talking technology
completely is the people you've got to
have the right people and really invest
heavily in your people not only just who
you're hiring but the training they get
and the ability to to to learn more what
they're doing but if we're talking
technology wise um you for me I'm going
to have to say because of the the best
bang for the buck that I've gotten so
far it's going to have to be from for
the posit and I'm not saying that
because I'm at a posit conference I know
somebody set up that question but thank
you for asking that question but it it
allows me for for for the for the money
for the a number of you users we can
access it allows me to do so many
different things
you know with with Tableau and no
offense Tableau I can only do one thing
I can visualize some kind of business
intelligence capability if I need to
send data back to my server I can't do
that from Tableau you know so if I need
a pipeline that's going back and forth I
need something different and and my
investment in posit has definitely paid
off a lot
more that's great to hear El do you want
to add anything yeah I agree definitely
on the you know the middle to end of the
process the posit connect is versatile
and has been really valuable to really
like get the value from the investment
we've made in the data science humans um
I think on the other end another thing
that's always been worth the investment
is in data connectors so ways instead of
having to go through engineering anytime
there's an outof the-box connector where
you can buy something that someone else
is maintaining and worrying about all
the details that it gets the data
directly into your Warehouse so you can
take it from there that's Al a great
investment I I'll just add one thing to
that because something I've always
thought about when I was starting off
with r early on it said there there's
like the App Store there's a package for
that and there's always been that if I
needed to do something figure out a way
to do it that I can definitely get a
packageing that open source capability
along with commercializing and put it
into an Enterprise version I know that I
have a way of doing things like a was
saying I get those packages built
somewhere else to do these things so
it's helped me a lot utilizing some of
those tools and capabilities ities
definitely okay one um question for you
elene
was going back to the framework that you
showed us do you have any tips for
seeking out opportunities when you
aren't always invited to the business
meetings yeah this is a great question
and I've uh I believe I have asked this
question of other people at previous
posit conferences how do how do I get in
the room where all of this is happening
um so I I
think you have to kind of give up
initially on actually you know getting
in the leadership meeting if if you're
not there already and instead make
friends with people who are in those
meetings and see you know ask good
questions pay attention in your your
companywide meetings and think about
what's going on with the business or the
organization that you're part of and and
like put yourself in the head of those
leaders and what they care about and
then people usually are not trying to
keep you from knowing things um so I
think yeah asking a lot of questions
going to lunch with people setting up
Zoom meetings and just really being
heads up about thinking about you know
what they're thinking about and how you
can address it one thing I I'd like to
add to that is at least in in what I've
seen at NAS is find a mentor that knows
is connected as Network somebody that
you can talk to utilize and ask them
those questions you know how do I do
this how do I connect many times they'll
make the introductions and make the
connections for you or they know who
they can who they can do that or what
they can do so start reaching out
because those type of people want to
share their information they want to
share their knowledge so ask them you'll
be surprised how many people say yes
I'll Mentor you on these things y thank
you both so much I uh there are so many
amazing questions still left in slido
and so I have to use this opportunity to
also say like we get to talk about
things like this every Thursday at the
data science hangout if anybody wants to
join us virtually there um we've had
conversations with Elaine and David
there but every week we have a a
different featured leader who joins us
from the community so I would love to
have you all join us there um but with
that I know we have to get out to our
break I want you to be able to grab some
coffee stretch your legs check out the
lounge before our next keynote back here
at 10:30 but thank you so much elain and
David for your presentation today thank
you